I'm Jake Sadler i'm from pontypool wales
started off looking into investing I
could make my money work for me
and then I eventually came across
property investments and some release
was the first YouTube channel to Papa
I had to the competition about three
four days later right now me and Amelia
are gonna select one person to win four
thousand pounds credit and this is going
to be completely random right okay could
be you one winner is Jake Sandler Jake
congratulations man your life is about
to change
yeah what's up Jake
what you doing bro cool buddy listen
just wanted to say congratulations you
won the four thousand pound training
credit man it's great man it's great man
it just means you it just means you're
gonna be able to do some training with
us get some knowledge get some knowledge
and become financially free so how you
feeling
we need to read sorry we're gonna we're
gonna redo the prize draw you weren't
excited enough hold on hold on I'll call
you back now anyway Matt I would look
forward to working with you and as I
once again massive congrats it's like
it's prettier he's pretty good pretty
good yeah Jake's gonna look back on this
moment what day is it October the fourth
fifth whatever it is seventh
Jason look back on this moment on the
seventh and say damn I should have been
more excited than that at the time I
didn't believe it so I was a bit bit
dull and there wasn't much reaction
afterwards I called him back and then it
actually Ted I drew him and then I went
wild who's this hey yes it was me bro
dude you come in on the advanced
training yeah we've got you skipped man
4,000 pound credit I thought you didn't
sound excited earlier dude man I look
for to getting to know you
I'll get I'll get the guys to send you
out a confirmation in the next few hours
all right bless you bro thanks Jackie
awesome he thought it was a trick that's
what he wasn't excited to the property
I'd like to do every every form of
investment lease option agreement by
refinance refurbish rental ran as many
things I can do I think it's the one of
the only forms of investment that is
safer than say start business but then
it will give you more cash flow then say
stocks and shares you draw the program
yeah it's been worth it some nice man so
you're doing the deal finding
extravaganza never you remember the end
program where we go the regimental yeah
well and that's that's fun new was
filming you with winning us filming you
on record when you are you know I got a
phone call off here and then it was like
a stallion I thought I saw like a robot
call yeah that's like you don't expect
you really did but you know it's like
what is a lot real most and then that's
why I called you back and now I knew is
real and then I went wild so nice what
you got them from this
what's gonna happen this weekend help me
this again yeah it's ER even though I
knew sort of basics yeah it was sort of
like I couldn't really imagine how how I
go about it so watching you do it and
then house to find a hitch and things
like that really to build on top of the
knowledge that I already don't know
that's great so what was next probably
focus on deal sourcing as well as read
to write school burn some people up see
what I can do it was actually I found
the program even though I sort of
dragged him along along to it I don't
want to drive he's probably enjoyed it
more than I am yeah yeah just someone
that said to you how are you 18 yeah
someone said to your 18 knows between
you serious how do you feel about that
well I mean there's some of you worried
about or you like now know why I
wouldn't kill it you know I was worried
about it but now I've seen like James
you know just come up with about 65 Kate
deal yeah
just as a deal sources not to mention it
any other properties that's right
so I guess seen other people doing it
when they're young it just yeah that's
awesome I did I'm well excited about see
it's a lot good job I did the deal
finding extravaganza so that is on
November 20th and I just went to see how
that is and hopefully I'll be great
thank you so much has been a great
challenge listen everyone's a winner
though because the crash course is free
so if you've not booked on the property
investors crash course I'm gonna put a
link below in the description on the
house cost us tens of thousands to put
the events on with all the lighting and
the stage and the audios and visuals and
the music and the room hire we put it on
for free why because we are on an
absolute mission to see as many people
as possible become financially free
through property I even make my staff
you you've done the training your mom
has done the training
how's she getting on get on the training
man links below I'll see you there